steamy co-ed showers gigantic bizarre
space insects a young neil patrick
harris these paws worthy moments from
starship troopers are just the start
keep watching to see more starship
troopers is considered to be the third
of paul verhoeven's so-called triple
dutch trilogy following up the hit
sci-fi satires robocop and total recall
those films similarly mix gleefully
provocative imagery and brutality with
off-putting over-the-top screen
programming to drive their themes home
and starship troopers is no different
the fascist propaganda scene on its
screens aren't meant to serve so much as
commercials as they are on-demand
information that bears an uncanny
resemblance to the internet or at least
the promise the internet held in its
1997 infancy it makes some sense as the
nascent world wide web held the promise
of allowing media consumers to move from
topic to topic with the click of a
cursor if you look hard enough you might
also detect faint traces of the always
online future to come the ability to
focus on top news could be seen as
predicting eventual social media
websites like twitter of course the
internet aspect of the movie's opening
montage hails in comparison to its
fascist overtones the sequence draws
directly from triumph of the will the
notorious lenny riefenstahl nazi
propaganda film complete with eagle
imagery as verhoeven who grew up under
nazi occupation told entertainment
weekly in 1997 when the soldiers look at
the camera and say i'm doing my part
that's from reef install we copied it
some images from starship troopers are
pause-worthy because of what we know
others because of what we never will
case in point the biology teacher from
the high school attended by starship
troopers protagonists johnny rico
carbony banez and carl jenkins
definitely has something going on that
warrants closer inspection she only
appears in a single scene but that scene
is impossible to ignore rue mcclanahan
of golden girls fame plays the teacher
who piles around her classroom as rico
and carmen dissecting our
sand beetle she extols the virtues of
the alien arachnids and proclaims the
foolishness inherent in any notion of
human superiority while the scene mostly
serves as a crash course in alien
biology for the audience it's impossible
to look away from the teacher whose
burn-like scars around her eyes suggest
that she's been blinded between her
aesthetic and her ideology it would be
fascinating to learn more about our
backstory if nothing else we just want
to keep the movie paused on mcclanahan
long enough to write our own fan fiction
backstory for her character
rico and his fellow mobile infantry
aspirants are trained by sergeant zim
played with over-the-top intensity by
clancy brown his drill sergeant
characterization is undoubtedly familiar
to anyone who's seen a war movie before
but brown along with jake busey also
delivers one of the film's most
memorable images one that definitely
subverts expectations and drives home
just how brutal boot camp can be in a
militaristic dystopia
let down on this sun
it helps
i know
bucy's mobile infantry recruit ace levy
is practicing throwing knives but is
having some trouble with it frustrated
he demands to know why the skill is
necessary to learn saying that most
combat in this particular future is
fought using nuclear weaponry which
merely requires the push of a button zim
in response commands ace to put his hand
against the nearby wall ace clearly has
no interest in doing so but reluctantly
follows the order in most movies the
payoff to this setup would be for zim to
throw a knife and intentionally miss
ace's hand or to hit something else with
the knife instead but not in starship
troopers zim throws the knife directly
into ace's palm pinning it to the wall
then calmly walks over and gives a
simple iconic explanation
the enemy cannot push a button if you
disable his hand
it's a classic moment that helps set the
entire film's tone
upon its late 90s release the co-ed
shower scene from starship troopers made
a lot of news all these years later the
scene is still as potentially abrasive
as a dry loofah mobile infantry recruits
both male and female all shower together
though as virgo vin has pointed out a
similar thing happens in the police
locker room in robocop perhaps for
hoeven's take on the future is simply
that it's going to result in a lot of
lawsuits the fact that the robocop scene
seemingly went unnoticed galvanized
rehoven to go even harder in the
starship trooper's showers which feature
an entire room full of beautiful young
actors not wearing any clothes but
that's not the reason to pause during
the scene what you want to examine are
the faces of the characters none of whom
display any sexual interest whatsoever
in those around them it turns out that
the shower scene means a lot more than
audiences initially thought as the
recruits discussed their lives and
ambitions the fact that they are doing
so while naked in the shower together
seems to barely matter to them as
verhoven told empire in 2014 these
so-called advanced people are without
libido it is sublimated because they are
fascist
in stark contrast to the shower scene
the tattoo scene doesn't have any deeper
thematic meaning but it's no less an
iconic image one that stood out in the
original trailer and features a tattoo
design that has since been used in a ton
of starship troopers merchandise it's
actually that very tattoo design that
makes this moment pause worthy think
about it why do four mobile infantry
soldiers who have just joined the
fighting force that deals exclusively in
ground warfare have tattoos that say
death from above it's particularly
confusing when you consider that right
before they get these tattoos rico gets
in a fight with xander barcalo an
officer of the fleet which does hit the
enemy from above
mobile infantry
in fact the tattoo design is a relic of
robert heinlein's book so much so that
it doesn't actually fit in verhoeven's
movie rehoven had nothing but contempt
for his source material to the extent
that his adaptation was specifically
designed to satirize it he changed a ton
including the fact that in the book the
mobile infantry dropped onto enemy
planets from orbit hence the slogan the
tattoos don't actually make sense for
the movie but they look really cool
one of the many changes made by
verhoeven in his adaptation of starship
troopers was to combine the character of
teacher john de bruyne with the
character of lieutenant radjak leader of
the mobile infantry platoon known as rad
jack's roughnecks this choice makes
sense in the book de bras sends rico a
letter revealing that he's a former
mobile infantry soldier so it's simply
economical to fuse them together this
also allows the movie to provide a
fantastic narrative moment in which the
audience realizes that the teacher has
become the soldier when radjak is still
in the classroom it's clear that he's
lost his left hand and most of his left
forearm no attempt is made to hide this
so when rico ace and dizzy join the
roughnecks and prepare to meet their
infamous lieutenant the close-up on a
cybernetic left arm instantly tells us
everything we need to know it's obvious
that the lieutenant is rajak before we
even see michael ironside's face again
and his seamless transition from
respected educator to battle commander
slightly transmits the propaganda stick
idea that rico and the roughnecks are
the good guys anything that conveys that
much information in a single shot is
absolutely worth pausing for
starship troopers might be a satire but
that doesn't mean it's not also a big
budget sci-fi blockbuster sometimes over
the course of the movie you just want to
pause to get a better look at some of
the creature designs the coolest looking
arachnid is undoubtedly the tanker buff
which first burst out of the ground
during a roughneck mission to tango
urilla massive in size it sports
sinister green eyes and a built-in
flamethrower for incinerating pesky
human soldiers if you pause the movie as
it emerges in the desert sun you can get
a good look at the attention to detail
that went into creating it it's clearly
alien but also recognizable as an insect
most people probably don't love the idea
of a gargantuan beetle that spews fire
at them but that's kind of the point
in the third act of starship troopers we
meet another kind of arachnid the brain
bug which resembles nothing so much as a
gigantic brain with eyes and pincers its
capture serves as the big climax of the
movie representing the first definitive
victory for humans over bugs along with
a potential wealth of new information on
how to fight them more effectively not
only is this moment pause worthy because
of another incredible alien design but
also because it marks the reappearance
of carl who has been largely absent from
the middle section of the film he's
clearly refined his latent psychic
powers in the years since he rico and
carmen were last together
it's afraid
this of course causes everybody to cheer
wildly and signals a clear triumph of
good over evil since in this case the
good guys are fascists and there's
nothing a fascist loves more than making
somebody else afraid
before the human's triumphant capture of
the brain bug it manages to take out one
of the movie's major characters xander
barcolo is first seen as rico's high
school sports rival and immediately hits
on carmen while rico ends up beating him
in the big game xander gets the girl
becoming carmen's pilot instructor
during her fleet training and ultimately
a good deal more than that xander is
kind of irritating and as an audience
we're trained to stand behind our
protagonist when he gets himself into a
love triangle however zander ultimately
proves to be a decent enough guy and
rico moves on to sleep with dizzy so
everything resolves itself pretty easily
still if one of these characters had to
get gray matter sucked out of their head
by the brain bug's feeding spike xander
would probably have been the audience's
first choice it's difficult to forget
this moment after seeing chunks of
xander's brain move through a
semi-transparent tube and into the brain
bug as it chows down greedily the worst
part is when it's all gone and the brain
bug makes a sound like it's sucking on
an empty straw xander's wide-eyed
hollowed-out head is an image that tends
to stick around in the mind
starship troopers is particularly
interested in the implications of young
people becoming soldiers the journeys of
rico carmen and carl happen mostly
separately but we still see them as kids
in high school before we see them as
soldiers or military officers we can see
the changes they endure by the movie's
conclusion carl is a leader in military
intelligence carmen is a fleet captain
and enrico is commanding the roughnecks
a platoon that suddenly includes several
brand new recruits before his first
mission as a lieutenant on planet p rico
looks over his newest soldiers most of
whom appear significantly younger than
the protagonists were when they began
training in the propaganda videos
throughout the film we've seen kids
dressing up as soldiers or smashing
ordinary bugs in the street to help the
war effort this moment takes that notion
to its logical extreme as the depleted
roughnecks are given literal children to
refill their ranks in the final sequence
of the movie rico can be seen repeating
radjak's words to egg his soldiers on
come on
[Music]
the message is clear the kids are going
to keep going into the meat grinder
punctuated by the final words that flash
across the screen they'll keep fighting
and they'll win check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite cult
classic movies are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
you